you're the president the organization
right right you're a big cheese yet you
still have this I don't know if it's
ceremonial or what your job is to
separate the fighters when they have the
pre-fight staredown yeah is that
something was that your idea or
something that just became part of your
job it just sort of happened yeah you
know I've been doing it for a long time
and obviously so the Athletic Commission
in every state which is basically the
government oversees us yeah and you know
in the fight business it's about not
letting guys touch each other if they
touch each other that you know they've
been training for months they've been
away from their family they're cutting
weight they're very agitated at that
point so it's about keeping them away
from each other and and making sure the
fight doesn't happen before the fight
well if we think it'd be an extremely
dangerous position to be in because
here's a picture of you I think it's
between your sting between Aldo and
McGregor and your job is and these are
two people that really do look like I
don't know how much of it's an act
they look like they want to kill each
other no they do yeah that was a rough
tour we actually went on a world tour
and every day I had to go through that
at least we squared him off every day in
a different City so yeah I've had some
I've had some good I'm getting old now
man I can't do it the way to it but I'd
give it the best shot well scuffles
break out frequently let these stair
downs oh yeah I've been involved in some
bad ones yeah what happened some of the
worst situations you've been in um you
know well the worst one that ever
happened that was on vacation and
somebody else was there was it was a guy
named Dave Schaller who's our head of PR
at the time and yeah when these guys
when people fill in for me they think
you're just standing up there you know
taking a picture and you know pose and
until things go bad and then you really
do have to work hard to make sure they
know know so sometimes so the guy will
win first he'll come over no standings
waiting for the other guy I can tell by
how fast and hard he's coming whether I
need to step in or not so that they
don't touch each other right we haven't
we've made a little montage of some of
your scuffles take a look
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
good job
I think that's put the girls in the
worst seems like you say the woman's
girl hurts by far the craziest man once
the girls get out there and start in in
all my years
Yoani on Jay check and Claudia go Delia
two of the best women in the world in
their weight class leading up to that
fight
punched elbowed need and kicked me about
50 times leading up to you know through
that season of The Ultimate Fighter and
leading up to the fight the fight was
amazing it sounds a little erotic not
you